good citizens of the reject Nation you
spoke I listened after that Monumental
villains list it is time to dive into
some Heroes now we cut this off at 75 a
whopping 75 Euros this could have easily
been like 150 200. honorable mention
goes out to The Howling Commandos to
Hogan to Hank and Janet themselves there
are so many heroes in the MCU at this
point that I had to limit this to 75
because it could have gone on forever
but here we have 75 of the greatest
heroes in the MCU ranked and right after
this break I'll tell you how we decided
to rank him but first do leave a like
comment let me know what else you want
to see I made this one because I saw
everyone say they wanted Heroes list so
here we are let me know what else you
want to see and do all the YouTube
things share this with your friends let
them know I will say before we get into
this I am a little under the weather
still so if there's a slight energy lull
I do apologize for all of you that like
being 11. I'm still like a nine but I'm
only human all right let's get into it
[Music]
all right so to make this list for me
I'm not gonna lie this took about two
hours to decide who is in what order
which Heroes I wanted to include which
ones would make the cut it was a long
process but I ended up breaking it down
to four key attributes one was their
transformation from the comic and that's
what's gonna make this list a little
more unique this is still based within
the MCU but if a character is between
like 50 and 49 that's what's gonna Edge
them over just a little bit is how well
I think they made them improve from the
comic book another thing was the
authenticity to their MCU Arc how
authentic one character feels from their
movie to a crossover movie to a team-up
movie all those things are very
important so their authenticity of their
Arc within the MCU another thing I had
in mind was how compelling they are how
much you want them on the screen how
entertaining they are how how much you
feel for them how much you feel like
them their authenticity to the character
and their overall development was very
important and lastly heroism itself
these are heroes so I took heroic
attributes into account so those are the
four main categories how heroic how
authentic how it translates from comic
and their overall Arc in the MCU and how
much that felt true let's get into it
coming in at number 75 is Gilgamesh now
Gilgamesh is from the eternals a movie I
espouse often I love this movie very
very much but what makes Gilgamesh Stand
Out is in a movie with an ensemble cache
he's especially heroic in the way he
handles not just the macro of the world
the catastrophizing the global stuff but
his relationship with Dina I love how
contained that relationship is I love
how human that relationship is and I
love what selflessness looks like for
Gilgamesh and that's what makes a hero
and that's a really unique relationship
really love this character really love
how he's used number 75. coming at
number 74 is fendral now he had the
deficit of being recast between his
first and second appearance but both
actors including the leading man
performance of Zachary Levi were very
charming and very intricate and very fun
there was a specificity to this
playfulness this Robin Hood ass
character that I did think elevated the
Thor films I wish we had a little bit
more of him I wish we got to learn a
little bit more about this character but
besides just being part of the Warriors
3 but I do think that Bond what um that
that brought out in Thor was very very
useful and I wish we could have seen
more to really flesh out Thor but for
now he's 74. coming in at number 73 in
the highest of the Warriors Three I did
mention Hogan was an honorable mention
at the top of this video he'd be like 78
if we did 100 of these but we've got
number 73 volstag as played by Ray
Stevenson now this man is a Powerhouse
he is our Punisher at times he is also
usually a Villain at other times he's
the villain of rrr this man is
everywhere and he brings so much levity
to this role very intense actor playing
a comedic role almost Santa claus-esque
I love the beauty of this comedy I love
the physicality of this comedy I love
that every time a volstag is on screen I
want to know more he's also someone who
sacrifices himself and that is about as
heroic as it gets while being a force of
levity while also being a force of power
like I would fear this character this
God of hunger and War full stack is
awesome check him out number 73 number
72 now this one might be a bit lower
than a lot of people would prefer but
there's a very specific reason for this
and that is going to be pepper pots as
rescue and that is mainly because her
two appearances as rescue as opposed to
being as pepper pots felt very
incomplete it felt like there were
scenes missing it felt like there were
edits I loved when we had moments of
heroism from pepper pots because the
pepperpot's Tony Stark relationship is
foundational to my love of a very high
up number on this list Tony Stark I love
what Pepper Potts represents and I love
what she does for the Stark Foundation I
love her keeping Tony in line I love her
being able to outsmart Tony on many many
terms and ways but I don't like that as
soon as you put on the suit it kind of
went away I did feel like all of the
intelligence and capability and
resourcefulness and all those things
that make pepper so interesting as soon
as the iron suits on it's another Iron
Man and that that puts her pretty low
because that's not the character so
rescue's pretty low for me while Pepper
Potts is high gotta land here at number
72. number 71 is a character I have not
understood and that has been very hard
for me in this age of comedy in the
Marvel ERA this is a character so many
people love and I don't get it uh he's
funny I laugh I don't really invest and
a lot of people really had a whole thing
to say especially in love and thunder
that is Korg I don't get the Korg thing
um he's perfectly fine and that is why
he's 71. perfectly fine cork coming at
number 70 is a character that I expect
to elevate as soon as her show comes out
this is a character I want to see more
of so I get the feelings I want to get
this is a character from David Mack one
of my favorite comic creators of all
time and I have not felt this from the
MCU version of the character yet and
that is Echo Echo is a fascinating
character in the comic books Echo is so
resourceful and enigmatic and
interesting and makes you lean into the
character and want to learn more about
her backstory and all these things and I
felt like the way she was used as
supporting character and the way she was
used in Hawkeye was almost like a
henchman and and that didn't feel right
didn't feel authentic it felt like she's
meant to be so much more and I didn't
get that from her yet the show coming
out is gonna flesh this character out
she will not live this low certainly by
this time uh next year two years from
now but for now with the portrayal we
got so far much like in my villains list
Kingpin from the Netflix series is one
of my favorite villains of all time hard
stop Kingpin in the MCU Allah Hawkeye is
one of my lower because of the
disappointment between the duality of
those characters much like Echo is going
to be lower here Echo is landing at
number seven coming in at number 69 is
Icarus now Icarus is in the eternals and
Icarus stands out as the Superman s
character and in an age of invincible
and the boys and all of these dark
Superman archetypes Icarus has a tall
order to do luckily he's played by
Richard Madden so he can carry that that
said the twist did feel fairly
telegraphed from earlier on in the film
luckily this movie has a lot of twists
this movie has a lot of turns this movie
goes a lot of places but I did feel like
Icarus was definitely a character I
would have loved to see more of for the
Twist and I do feel like it was a little
bit expected because of this age of Dark
Superman so I enjoyed the performance I
like the portrayal I understood most
importantly where he was coming from he
was following orders he was super cop he
was a cop just doing what he was told
and that did make him captivating that's
why he's not lower but the twist being
so telegraphed keeps him on the lower
side at number 69. number 68 likewise
with a Twist feeling a bit telegraphed
and that unfortunately shortchanging the
heroism and short-changing the character
I'm gonna go with Sharon Carter now
Sharon Carter totally works in Winter
Soldiers Sharon Carter totally works
throughout Civil War but by the time we
get to where her art goes as the power
broker I'm a lot less invested in the
character and that's not to fault the
actor just like none of these other
performances are are bad it felt like it
was to serve the plot not to serve the
character and sometimes when you're
making this giant tapestry of the MCU
some things have to serve the plot if it
short changes the character that's so be
it so unfortunately for now and I'm
hoping this changes with Thunderbolts
Sharon Carter number 68 I'm hoping to
see agent 13 evolve agent 13 will be rad
to see I'd like to see agent 13 more
than the power broker we'll see 68
Sharon Carter number 67 Red Guardian I
love David Harbor I love him a lot he's
fun he's interesting he's a delight to
interview he's a good man
I like David Harbor in the MCU I don't
however see where the red guardian's
gonna go as being important enough for
the Thunderbolt he was a very fun
supporting character in Black Widow
that's what I thought his purpose was
going to stay the opening of the film is
why he's as high as he is but that's not
when he's Red Guardian that's when he's
playing the Spy father of Black Widow
and and Yelena I want to
get more of that paternal nature and
more of the conflict I definitely by the
end felt the paternal conflict between
betraying his daughters but I want to
see more of that I do want to see him as
more of a hero I do think we're gonna
get that from Thunderbolts he's in a
tricky spot so he doesn't have a lot of
screen time yet so for now Mr David
Harbor is Red Guardian is number 67. all
right number 66 is not really a hero
at all but I felt like I had to include
him because I think to some people's
eyes he is a hero and his captivating
nature put him this high on the list
remember that was one of my factors what
makes them unique is also part of what
makes them heroic in this this judgment
this U.S agent now U.S agent is a
fascist following orders much like
Icarus so they're Heroes of their own
mind no one acts out of villainy but
he's definitely done things wrong but he
often times showed that his heart was in
the right place as far as his belief
like as long as he believed that would
help people he was doing it for helping
people that that's a hero but he hasn't
done a lot right yet so it's really
tricky I love the conflict I feel about
this character he is just following
orders he's following government orders
and that's that conflict from Winter
Soldier you know cap Steve Rogers
doesn't just follow Waters blindly and
that's what causes the conflict that
leads to Civil War from Winter Soldier
us agent would and he would do it from
the right place for the wrong reasons
very tricky character very excited to
see more of him in Thunderbolts we've
got Mr John Walker at number 66. all
right number 65 is going to be quick
because we don't really know them as a
hero yet but they deserve an honorable
mention because I love them dearly
they're not hero yet because they're
kind of a punk they cause a lot of
problems they're a bit of a nuisance but
every time they're on screen I'm so
happy they're usually dancing this is
Baby Groot slash teenage Groot about to
get into some heroism we've seen the
Guardians the Galaxy 3 trailer we're
gonna see what swole Groot brings
remember Groot OG and this group
separate groups Baby Groot has caused
more problems than good so far but he's
adorable and he has done some heroic
acts so I gotta put them a little higher
than a lot of these people Baby Groot I
love you number 64 and one of my biggest
surprises of the MCU shows I did not
expect this character this is a very
deep cut character in a deep cut show
I've always considered Moon Knight to be
you know a c-less character I never
thought would get the time of day and
then Scarlet Scarab are number 64.
Scarlett's carob this actress every time
she was on screen I was so enamored and
fascinated and I wanted to know more
about the relationship and I and I was
was more intrigued by the disassociative
identity of all of the Oscar Isaacs
because of her performance and then when
you give her the full superhero
treatment she gets those awesome Wings
we get a little bit of action from her
in heroic character we got lots of
action from her just as a civilian
badass performance a lot of great stunt
work a lot of practical work and earned
her wings earned the heroism really
enjoyed to this take I want to see more
from Scarlet Scarab but she's number 64.
number 63 is higher than would have
expected but I couldn't think of a place
to put him on the list any lower and
it's it's because of the limited screen
time I was just so impressed at what he
was able to do so quickly this is a
character that I don't particularly love
from the comic books I don't mind him
but I'm never invested like I read his
comics and I and I bought his mini
series but I wasn't like this guy's my
guy that's Black Bolt I was so impressed
at what Anson Mount did with Black Bolt
in very little screen time and no
dialogue obviously as Black Polk can't
speak this man emanated reality he
emanated power he emanated an interest
you wanted to know more about him he
took out Thanos like in in the matter of
minutes I love that elseworld scene or
that alternate universe scene of him and
the Moon that beautiful Illuminati shot
of all of them taking out Thanos is so
powerful and he's the only member of the
Illuminati that makes this list because
what he was able to do with so little
was so impressive and it's the character
I want to see more of if we do an else
world what if jump into any of those
other multiverses really liked Hanson
Mount as uh the great Black Bolt number
63. all right we got a newcomer here
coming in at number 62 she just made her
debut in wakanda forever and she is
about to get her own Series in Iron
Heart ever Charming Ever captivating
Dominique Thorne as ironheart now she
has a lot to balance she is a Legacy
character in that she puts out an Iron
Man suit they even call it out in the
movie she has to be witty and charming
and different she's got to have a
different kind of Street smarts than
anybody we've met before she's from a
very rough neighborhood and then MIT so
she's got to deal with that polish
versus Street there's so much to this
character and I think they nailed it I
personally am a big fan of Brian Michael
bennison iron Hearts I personally think
Dominic Thorne the moment she walked on
stage at Comic-Con I saw ironheart very
excited to see more from her she without
again much screen time already made a
great impression she's number 62.
ironheart coming in at number 61. we
just got her as a hero and prior we'd
loved her as Jane Foster that is the
Mighty Thor now this one's tricky
because I love Natalie Portman so much
it's hard to separate my problems with
writing and directing from the
performance I think she is a comedic
Powerhouse if you've never seen any of
her SNL work but some of the comedy
stylings of the movie themselves didn't
suit the MCU or Natalie Portman that
said I was so invested in Jane Foster
that I would have rather had a Jane
Foster movie I would have rather had the
battle with cancer I would have rather
had you know scenes of her deciding to
pick up the hammer again I would have
rather had her Heroes Journey her
discovering these powers and instead it
felt like obviously we've had four for
four movies we're following his journey
and she was popping up in moments as
this new character and yeah we'd lived
with Jane Foster but I wanted more
Mighty Thor than fact that I wanted more
Mighty Thor puts her pretty high in this
list because I do think Jane Foster and
Natalie Portman did what they could with
the time they had Mighty Thor all right
number 60. we got a guy that shouldn't
died we got a fella that uh was taken
out too soon I don't know if it was a
personal Vendetta from John Sweden or
what but Quicksilver getting shot is
preposterous what Aaron Taylor Johnson
was able to do in his charm in his
chemistry with his sister you heard me
in his ability to make every scene with
him be different and unique and go up
against an already in theaters
Quicksilver Remember The Days of Future
Past sorry no remember the the other
X-Men movie came out right around the
same time as this so he had a very tall
order Evan Peters brought this very
different Quicksilver and this was an
Avengers Quicksilver and it still felt
unique and special I didn't love the
outfit but I love the performance I love
the heroism I love the sacrifice I love
that Pietro got to be a bit of a punk
but also a hero and that's the character
had a great time with him died too soon
Quicksilver Pietro 60. number 59 and we
are going back to the world of eternals
with fastos now fastos is a key anchor
in this giant film fastos is the one
that makes the family feel like a family
and that's in him having a family and I
loved how immediately I loved him and
his family I was so enamored by what
Brian Tyree Henry brought he's the
inventor and he invents this nuclear
family and I love that I love that we
immediately want to know more about how
much influence he said in humanity I
love how immediately his selflessness
goes against all of his programming and
everything he's been told to do I love
that he's always been about us and a bit
about the underdog been about the little
guy I am about fastos as a character and
definitely in this delivery definitely
this performance I think Brian Tyree
Henry was a standout in a very stacked
cast and I think fastos was the heart of
a very very beautiful family that is the
eternals love this movie coming in at
number 58 sticking with eternals and
this is my second favorite Eternal yes
there's like five of the nine eternals
on this list I love that movie but this
one is so important to me on the macro
scale because we look at Heroes and we
think of Heroes as being you know
infallible in a way we look at Heroes as
unbreakable it's one of the reasons I
don't identify with Superman as much I
like when Heroes have flaws that I can
identify with and I never thought we'd
get a character identifying with mental
health so directly as Athena Athena's
mental health was her strength in the
film and that was beautiful if she
didn't have those mental struggles she
wouldn't have been able to see what she
saw and that wouldn't have made the
eternals aware of the truth sometimes
what people perceive as a weakness is a
strength and sometimes when people
perceive as mental health is their
greatest strength this character is very
important to me as someone who struggles
with mental health this character is
very important to me as someone who
thinks we need more representation of
characters like this on screen and as
someone who loves that Angelina Jolie
chose to play a character like this to
put her name behind something like this
to bring that movie star
bravado Gusto gravitas whatever you want
to call it Angelina Jolie asthena is a
really important character and a very
powerful character loved her to death
She's high up on this list number 57 is
Jack Russell AKA werewolf by Knight
World by night is a fascinating
character because you've got a mercenary
thrown in over his head at the top but
then you add all the supernatural
elements and particularly in this case
in this adaptation you do all this in 47
minutes you're empathetic to this
character right away your sympathetic
throughout the entire transformation and
every time he's on screen you feel like
you're learning more of his history just
through his eyes you feel like you're
getting more of the character every
single moment without gluttonous
expositionary dialogue there's so much
going on under the surface and in the
dialogue you get a rich tapestry of
character in 47 minutes through a
performance World by night is awesome
want more number 56 I was wrong there's
two more eternals guys spoiler alert I
like the eternals Makari Makari is
another great example of how you can
wheel build a character That's Unique
correctly this was a character who's
deaf that doesn't feel like it's some
sort of uh inclusionary panhandling this
is a character that represents something
to people this is a character that
people can look to and go that's me on
the screen and she does it so
magnificently so so deftly so so
beautifully the the choreography of her
movements the way she just moves through
the frame this actress is able to do so
much and it's so beautiful and it's so
seemingly authentic to who she is the
actress and the character Makari has
some of the best action in the MCU that
final action set piece I don't care what
flash footage you show me that Makari
stuff is so incredible and she stays so
passionate through the film and her
relationship with my number one internal
who's coming up later is also a key part
of why I love that movie and that wasn't
even scripted those characters just had
great chemistry and when things like
that happen that's so real we're gonna
have organic relationships happen on set
that cause Sparks that cause on camera
into on script into the movie changes
love that love Makari number 50
. I have a character if you showed me
the first one of these movies I would
never be like that's my guy please turn
it into my guy he is played by the
director's brother and he is craglin
craiglin is fascinating I don't know
what it is about him I always want more
crackling on screen you got a cast of
actors that I know very well by the time
you know these movies are coming out you
got Chris Pratt as a movie star you got
Zoe Saldana who's like in the biggest
movies ever between Avatar and the
Marvel Universe these are these are
Titans and I'm like James Gunn's brother
he's got something going on you tell me
more about Shang gun Annie's Rocket's
body like he's walking around like this
guy does so much and there's something
just so interesting about how Earnest he
is like the ravagers have something so
us about them there's this Underdog
thing to the Guardians for sure they're
the the a-holes of the universe but the
ravagers are just like getting by man
and cragland's just one of the guys
getting by he's that mechanic you trust
and I love that craglin 55 at number 54
you're probably wondering hey why'd you
talk about werewolf by night you didn't
talk about man thing well that's because
he's higher up because man thing is not
only
a thing I never thought would work but
not only did he work he kind of became
the MVP of this movie he has moments
where his power is terrifying but you
still want to hug him his beautiful like
elephant eyes that are so you're
enamored you're you're pulled into him
and yet he's a creature that warps
reality and you don't know a lot about
him but you know you want to know more
he doesn't really speak you have to talk
through jack russell to understand
what's going on his name's Ted which is
delightful I just everything about him
is great and as far as heroism he's a
cornered animal and he still doesn't
attack people until he needs to and
that's impressive this is something
that's been chased his whole life he's
been seen as a monster he's been seen as
a beast and he still has a sense of
humor he's still as a best friend he's
still able to see the good in things and
that's that's all we can hope for really
number 53 I'm gonna get some crap for
this I'm gonna take a little sip
I'm excited for her to be hired I'm
excited for the movie she gets this year
where I hope she's higher and uh you
know the movie made a billion dollars it
wasn't for me and that means it was for
a lot of people which is great I'm happy
when something makes money that isn't
for me because a lot of artists got paid
I
love I'll say the word love I love Brie
Larson the actress the person I like
Captain Marvel the character the hero I
have not seen those come together yet
I've seen tastes I've seen pieces and I
love the pieces enough that they're this
High 53 is an optimistic 53's belief in
the future but I didn't feel the
Charisma that Brie Larson has coming out
through Captain Marvel I didn't feel the
Charming stoicism that Captain Marvel
has coming out through the character I I
feel like there's some Block in the
middle I can see the pieces I am very
excited for them to come together number
52 is the second iteration of character
the first of which got an honorable
mention I said Hank and Janet at the top
honorable mention this is wasp now
Evangeline Lily is one of those
actresses that whenever she shows up
you're interested she just has that
movie star quality that said I put her
this low in the list because the entire
first movie spends a lot of the time
going hey I could do this better hey why
are we training this guy hey I can do
this better and it took until the second
movie for her get to do that that's not
her fault but it definitely made me feel
like this sense of frustrated stagnation
about the character because it's like I
feel like wasp but wouldn't have taken
no for an answer like she wouldn't have
listened to people being like you sit
down and that's not fair to the
character but it's also not fair to
where to put her on this list because I
didn't get that until the second movie
the second movie She's exceptional I'm
very excited for the scales to balance
and for her to get to be two-thirds of
the time awesome but that first movie is
really frustrating seeing her not get to
be why wasp and play a sidekick she's
not a sidekick it's Ant-Man and the WASP
they're on the same type level and there
she is I'm excited to see more of that
number 51 is a guy who was miscast
because he should have been a lead and
that Cass is a supporting part and I was
like don't you do that he's Idris Elba
heimdell is awesome heimdell could have
been Thor heimdell is a force of Nature
and heimdell Andy driselba both deserve
better I just feel like heimdell when he
shows up I'm always there uh you know
Thor Ragnarok he gets some really badass
action scenes which is why he's as high
up as he is a lot of this is Idris Elba
love I'll totally own that a lot of this
is just me being a big fan of Idris Elba
I wish that I could put heimdell in the
top 50 and that's Baby Wise 51 so I'm
like my guy the character in the comic
books is between one note and
fascinating like they don't give him a
lot of time but when he gets time to
dive in you're like this guy I feel the
same buddy Idris elba's taking the
character whenever they let Idris Play
I'm all in and and he got more screen
time throughout the movies spoiler alert
for a movie from the summer the post
credit scene I was like oh good they
realize how great Easter zombies
heimdell is but I just felt like it was
too little too late give me give me a
another world where he plays Thor
himself and I'm only or you just Zelda
or him now actually matter of fact you
bring back Idris Elba as Beta Ray Bill
as the voice of Beta Ray Bill and you
solve all these problems keep them on
the payroll keep him in Asgard number 50
is the one that's gonna get a lot of
people upset with me but hey it means
comments in the chat it means Greg's
happy it sucks all the things it is
Spider-Man
Toby Maguire you heard me Spider-Man
Toby McGuire okay so what heroes are is
people that go through arcs and gret
what I struggle with with the original
Sam Raimi topangaire films is that he
stays angry and so the Nerds when they
react to things there's there's nerds
that get even and there's nerds that
realize that they don't have to get even
you have people that are like I'm gonna
get my bullies back in 20 years and
there's people that are like I'm gonna
actually go be a successful CEO and
forget the dude that peaked in high
school I think the way that Toby played
Spider-Man was the dude that's gonna
have revenge on Flash Thompson in 20
years it's not healthy he cheats on Mary
Jane he kisses Gwen Stacy in front of
Mary Jane he upside down kisses he does
the trademark thing we all love from the
first film to cheat on the woman of his
dreams I get you have to introduce Gwen
Stacy I get you've got to grow the
character cast out but that is the least
authentic Spider-Man thing ever the
reason Peter Parker the nerdy guy that's
so charming and good at science has all
these beautiful women around him in the
comic books is because he respects them
all and all these women realize how rare
that is what is Toby McGuire's Peter
Parker do disrespects Mary Jane to her
face I don't I don't like it I don't
feel good about it but I will say in no
way home they redeem it in no way home
he addresses all that he talks about how
he uh has had to work on some things
he's a much more mature take in the
character the Tobey Maguire in no way
home is much more than Peter Parker I
always hoped he'd be by the third film
and eventually got to be so it is higher
than it might you know would be
otherwise without knowing home and it's
on this list because of no way home
because that's the MCU inclusion so I
will respect fleeks I know a lot of
people love those films it's just not my
characterization and it does demean the
heroic aspects and certain elements of
what Spider-Man is the train scene
notwithstanding that some heroism
obviously but everyone knows his
identity anyway Spider-Man number 50.
all right I got that off my chest number
49 Agent Phil Coulson I am gonna take
this uh you know the MCU route and uh
it's gonna be just the movies I consider
Phil Coulson to have died in The
Avengers because they needed something
to avenge I respect Agents of Shield but
I'm only going off he got so many great
moments in the movies and that's that's
what I love is
if you have a character die in the
course of Duty and literally be the
thing that names The Avengers that's
about as heroic as it gets that is
beautiful writing that is a reason for
these characters names that gives you a
very unique MCU flavor there is no Phil
Coulson in the comic books there is no
we need to avenge singular character I
love that they focused in on this one
wonderful man masterfully played by
Clark reg as this take on the character
I I think he's he's perfect uh from the
trading cards to the use of the trading
cards as something to avenge like
everything about this character is is
Pitch Perfect earlier in the in the
movie uh the movies when when you don't
have a first name your first name is
Agent there's just so much about this
character that is so beautifully sterile
government but every time you see a
little bit of fill you're really happy
about it Andy's a hero to sacrifice
himself love me some Phil Coulson number
49 just above Phil Coulson is the great
Maria hill now she is in the comic books
and she's someone who I always saw as a
great asset amongst the shield chess
pieces and then they cast Kobe smolders
and she brought so much more than a
chess piece I mean I'd watch a Maria
Hill movie and I would not have said
that before seeing what Kobe's Boulders
brought to this role I want to see a spy
movie with Maria Hill I want to see what
she thinks of the Segovia Accords I want
to see what she thinks of kamala's law
if that goes forward I want to see what
she thinks of the the She-Hulk
legislation that's going to pass I'm so
curious about this human amongst Gods
now that's more DC's thing right like
where they put you know us here and the
eye line is up at these Gods but Maria
Hill's a great example so is Phil
Coulson of what it's like to have
regular people around metahumans and how
they can be heroes too and that's what
makes her so special 48. coming in at
number 47 is another Eternal I realize
there are a lot of eternals in this list
that the cast is huge but this one I
thought they did a really cool job
making him feel like he's part of the
world the tapestry of the world and
making him the most Marvel character in
this very Art House film that is Kingo I
think Kingo has played
did a lot of heavy lifting comedically
but also didn't really let off the drama
you still cared about this character and
I love the idea of him playing his own
grandson him playing like his self
Through the Ages and it shows what a
more immortality would be like in
reality in a really cool way and it also
shows what it'd be like to be trapped in
that that running joke of your own life
and to do all those things and then when
they Incorporated him into Miss Marvel
when they made him a broader Hero on the
world stage it just made him such an
interesting character to me so it was it
was Camille's portrayal and then Miss
Marvel that really elevated him to this
point so uh we got Kingo pretty high at
number 47 number 46 Monica Rambo Now One
Division season was quite a long time
ago and when it was one division season
we all sat strapped to our chairs
wrapped that attention at this new thing
what was this MCU show what were these
Mysteries what's going on and a huge
part of that and a lot of people
remember you know the the Wanda and
vision of One Division but Monica Rambo
comic fans knew she became Spectrum or
Photon depending on which continuity and
a lot of fan know that she's a Captain
Marvel we we had that and we were like
when's it gonna happen what's going on
is that gonna be another follow-up
what's she was part of the mystery in
the Intrigue but what made this
portrayal so interesting was she was day
to day in Wanda's Life as a best friend
and I completely bought they might just
have that be the character I thought
what if they changed comic continuity
and Wanda invented this person I thought
what if she's an agent of shield and
this is real and then they they still
managed to make a new and inventive
reality manipulation by way of Wanda
origin for this character that's totally
unique Canon to the MCU that works I
think better in a lot of ways because
now it makes sense she's Photon look at
the reality look at the imagery look at
all the things they did and the
characterization the delivery the
Friendship the portrayal I bought all of
it love this take and I cannot wait for
the Marvels in part because of how great
Monica Rambo was not to mention not to
mention the daughter thing we met her
young in Captain Marvel what a great way
to tie in all those elements man I
really dug that the daughter of the
character met before as played by
Lashana Lynch that element where you use
time travel in a linear time way
endearing as to the character without
even having better genius there's so
many elements of this character I dig
all right into our top 45 and this is a
character that had a lot to do and
actually got moved movies for her
introduction which I can't imagine as an
actor having to do America's Chavez
America Chavez we were supposed to get
no way home she was supposed to open the
portals to bring in the Spiderman but
then she was moved to Doctor Strange
coveted stuff happened not Shenanigans
ensued and she was able to do so much
while basically being an exposition
Chase character she runs throughout this
whole movie and the charm of Sochi Gomez
is what makes this work if you had a
lesser actress in this role if you had a
less interesting character in this movie
it doesn't work this this perfect storm
of what America Chavez had to be
immediately endeared to this new
character immediately curious in this
young Avenger I want to see the Young
Avengers in part because of shochi's
performance and there are definitely
flaws uh the the exposition moment with
the memory dump did not work for me but
she recovered from it the character
worked and I want more for so uh America
shot that's 45 number 44 and okay this
is the last Eternal I promise I got a
lot of biases here uh one I love the
actor playing him two it was great to
hear an Irish accent in the MCU and
three I love the idea of humanity being
what's more important free will or
happiness druig is that as a hero and
he's an anti-hero just like he is in the
comic books druig is not someone you
trust druk's not someone you like but
you like him in the movie in part
because of a relationship with Makari in
part because Barry kejone is a goddamn
Mastermind of an actor and in part
because you kind of identify with where
he's coming from the opiate of the
masses the the concept of just being
like screw it just guide me through this
world I don't want to make decisions
it's hard to be a person and he was
right in a lot of ways that it is nice
to just not have to make decisions how
great is it when sometimes someone makes
dinner for you and just a surprise don't
worry about it here's dinner he did that
for an entire cult and he made him happy
is that good no it's no free will it's a
great great question I'm not saying I
agree with Colts I'm not saying I agree
with mind washing but brainwashing but I
am saying it's a fascinating character
and at the end of the day he chose the
right thing that's what makes him a hero
at the end of the day he chose the side
of freeing people of letting humans make
their own decisions and uh Barry Keon
man love this guy number 44 druick
number 43 is higher up than she would
have been even a month ago because she
finally got her time in the Sun and that
is mantis thanks to the holiday special
mantis hadn't gotten a lot of her own
solo time she hadn't got a lot of
Spotlight time but when she did it shown
why Palm clementif was cast like this
was just a pumpkin show the holiday
special was to show how incredible Palm
was not only is she to make childlike
Wonder not boring or childish or one
note but she's able to make it what we
want to see the world as and what better
place than a Christmas special right
that wonders of Christmas but she's
always trying to do the right thing like
she she doesn't want to hurt anyone she
endures going through the the horrors of
Thanos she puts herself In Harm's Way
She sacrifices a lot she wants Peter
Quill to be happy even at her own guilt
she shoulders the knowledge of the twist
of holiday special for Peter she's a
hero always sacrificing always looking
out for others always taking care of
others while being adorable endearing
and great comedically love me semantis
I'm so glad the holiday special gave her
time to shine number 42 is the wonderful
the captivating the Charming the
interesting the Tatiana maslani She-Hulk
this one was hard to rank because
frankly episodes one and two and eight
and nine of shulk are some of my
favorite MCU the middle I did struggle
through and I understand why some
elements in the middle were written the
way they were because of episodes eight
and nine but that doesn't change the
fact that I don't don't feel like we got
enough of the the intelligence of Shield
we didn't get enough of the witty in
court drama of Shield we saw a lot with
Daredevil certainly we saw shield and
Daredevil exchange witty barbs but what
she elk represents is being more
intelligent than so many people
including sometimes the audience I would
love to in a season two see more of that
in the courtroom it's an anti-trolling
Choice which I respect because trolls
can off but it is also a choice that
puts us in a position of not knowing
where to put her as a hero she didn't
actually have a villain to fight she had
the concept of trolls to fight when she
has to fight the leader when she has to
do these things I'm very excited for it
we did see elements we did see her
fighting alongside Wong we did see her
do heroic things which is why she's as
high as she is and because I love the
character and because she was truly
again Charming intelligent fun pithy all
the things you want from Shield I just
really need to see a little bit more to
put her any higher that said she's very
high she's about halfway up because I
love me some shield and I really think
they nailed a near impossible character
if you'd asked me a list of 10
impossible Marvel characters to
translate she elk would absolutely have
been on that and they did it coming in
at number 41. okay this is uh this is a
fun one because I would not have ever
expected this character to make this
list up until the year the show came out
I think it was last year Mobius is not a
character that I go man I want me some
Mobius television Owen Wilson is not a
character I would have thought man I
want me some Owen Wilson in the MCU I
love Owen Wilson I just would never have
thought his Wes Anderson wow of goodness
would fit and yet I have never wanted
anything more than to see a man on a jet
ski and that is the power of Owen Wilson
as Mobius Mobius is lawful good to the
level that it's the perfect counter to
Loki Loki is a bad guy gone good you
need that lawful good to counter him
lawful good is the least interesting
thing I don't usually again I bring up
Superman I don't usually get enthralled
by Superman comics I don't usually
invest in the world of lawful good it's
not my thing Mobius is somehow so good
and so right and so charming and so Owen
Wilson that he's number 41 Mobius
it is a mobin time is it
guys number 41 it's mobin time all right
top 40. we are about halfway we got
Nakia Nakia from the Black Panther
movies is
so I keep using the word captivating but
I think this is the most captivating a
character has been with what she does in
every frame well Appia Nyong'o one of
the most stunning people to ever exist
in a character that has to be that she's
a spy she's an ambassador she is a
representative of her country she cares
about everyone the citizens the very
people of the country she doesn't want
to get caught up in the the king queen
Madness she doesn't want to deal with
the world she wants to know t'challa not
King t'challa and somehow they're able
to do that and they're able to translate
that and she's able to be seen as
nothing but heroic nothing but helpful
in the second movie you find out she's
sacrificed even going to t'challa's
funeral in order to protect the secret
of Prince t'challa that's heroic that's
selfless that's beautiful and to do it
while helping people in Haiti to do it
while being on the ground on the
Forefront on the front lines of helping
people that need it most beautiful I
just like that's a hero and and maybe of
of the characters I've talked about so
far like maybe the most real hero like
people that are helping people in Haiti
people that are feeding people that
people that are making sure that
citizens of countries are are okay those
are heroes and Nakia man what a what a
role what a hero what a performance
number 39 we got Moon Knight okay so
Moon night's tricky because I love this
show until the last episode last episode
wasn't even that bad but it did the
thing that she all made fun of with the
giant Marvel fight problem so it's
really hard for me to uh separate my
feeling of how the show left me feeling
versus how I felt during the show I
Remember Loving the show watched it here
with the guys we had a great time and I
remember being like Oh my God they did
it they made Moon night how are they
doing this I think Moon Knight might be
some of the best acting in the MCU I
think Oscar Isaac's portrayal of Moon
Knight is absolutely and I think the
unique aspect of my criteria is
absolutely here I think it's one of the
most unique characters I think it's one
of the most unique portrayals things one
of those unique shows I think we saw him
be heroic I think we also saw him be not
heroic which also is interesting to give
you the dichotomy The Duality it's also
a character that we don't necessarily
have a guarantee of getting more of
we've heard season two sure but I want
to see more of him before I really
decide where he goes he was very
consciously right in the middle because
I love Moon Knight I never thought we'd
see him he's alongside shield in that 10
character I never thought we'd see but I
don't know how I feel about where I left
him and that's not the character's fault
so as far as the characters portrayed I
give him a very high B which is in this
mid-range love me some Moon number 38 is
wongalicious uh Wong has in phase four
gotten so much more screen time for good
reason Wong is effectively her Nick Fury
right now recruiting what's either going
to be the dark Avengers or the Young
Avengers we'll see but what is so great
about Wong is he always makes the right
move but he always does it begrudgingly
I love that Wong always wants a sandwich
more than he wants to fight the bad guys
and I also love that he'll always fight
the bad guys this is a guy that we met
basically guarding the the sacred books
at karmotage listening to Beyonce and
that's that's a Bop right there that's a
man that knows taste eloquence and had
to be the right guy on the right side of
the line and then we get endeared to him
he's the classic character that like is
stiff and stoic and breaks and you fall
in love with him and we absolutely have
and to this point he's watching Breaking
Bad so I don't know he's a very human
character to be the master of the Mystic
Arts he's also one of the most powerful
characters in the MCU and Benedict Wong
makes him personable and that's what you
want to hear number 37 now we're getting
to the point where this is a struggle I
think from I mean really from 40 up it
was it was Nakia could be in the top 30.
Moon Knight could be in the top like
once you get past 40 it is is anyone's
game but now it's real real hard because
37 Kevin Smith's number here Peggy
Carter is a character I've Loved from
the beginning Peggy Carter is a
character who is not as to me
interesting in the comic books Peggy
Carter serves as a North star for Steve
Rogers she so much more than that here
they made her a leader they made her
someone fighting on the front lines they
made her Agent Carter they made her
everything that Steve is in a no
disrespect Chris Evans even more
beautiful package I am so enamored by
Haley Atwell because she's able to be so
Regal and so eloquent and so a woman of
a bygone era while still being a modern
badass like there's something just so
timelessly captivating about Haley
Atwell which is the only way to play
this part this is a woman out of time
this is a woman we see in her 80s dying
in Steve Rogers arms that we have to
care for in the 40s a time that none of
us lived I mean someone watching this
might be 90. hello 90 year old what was
it like but overall that's not an
experience we have and yet there's
something about it that makes us feel
like she's from the 40s and then when
you've got Agent Carter you have to
immediately be endeared to her we get no
origin for her we just know she's
awesome and she is I don't know there's
something about uh Haley Atwell and
there's something about Peggy Carter
that I really love and it is to me
Superior than the comic take which puts
her pretty high 30 number 36 we're into
the other team we got through the
eternals now we're into the Guardians we
are going with Gamora Gamora has a very
hard job she is an alien assassin that
Star-Lord falls in love with Star-Lord
basically is our eye line into this
crazy universe and so we love Gamora and
that's a very hard role to play a
character that has all of her own
backstory with Thanos with her journey
and everything else but is also the
object of affection if you watch ROM
columns a lot of time either the male or
the female is underwritten whoever's
being pursued is often a little less of
an intricate character not as bad as it
used to be than the the pursuer and that
can easily happen in a role like this
and they didn't ever let that happen
you're always as fascinated by Gamora as
your Star-Lord her backstory is arguably
even more interesting even though the
film opens on star-lord's backstory
she's also green it's a character that
doesn't we don't identify like it's a
literal alien character but what Zoe
Saldana brings is this this incredible
openness this incredible Wonder this
incredible sense of even when she's
under duress you want to help she wants
to do the right thing even though
everything in her programming says not
to she's the daughter of Thanos and she
got out to help people even if some of
it's self-serving she's a guardian the
Galaxy for a reason and I'm really
excited to see what they do in three
with this new timeline Gamora why is
Gamora indeed all right we're gonna
stick with the Guardians of the Galaxy
and go with number 35. now this one's
tricky because this is a giant change
from the comics and I like them both
sometimes comic changes are for the
better like I think Peggy Carter is a
better character than she is in the
comic books Drax I think is great in
both iterations Drax is a Jim Starlin
character who's a lot more vicious in
the comic books but I think this really
fun literal take is so useful because
he's never dumb he's literal he's it's a
very unique kind of Comedy sometimes it
goes a little far I do think that in in
one of the in game or Avengers Infinity
War
um the the Frozen scene is a bit much
there are moments that go a little far
but overall the way he's written allows
you to feel a different kind of humor
that you need the Guardians of the
Galaxy movies are brutal they are
emotionally devastating and without
characters like Drax to bring you back
to have that whole relief of a laugh in
the middle of a cry you're out so I
think Drax in this form is absolute what
it needs to be and he's coming all from
a place of heartbreak the heroism is you
know Thanos destroyed his whole family
all of this is a Revenge tale and that
could be so boring and so one note but
it never becomes one note or boring
because what Dave Batista does with the
character Dave Batista makes you feel
every bit of his loss of family while
making you laugh with him not at him and
that's a hard thing to do and he's never
not a hero no decision he makes even
when he's being selfish somehow doesn't
serve others which is also a hard thing
to do love me some Drax number 34
sticking with them Guardians we got one
of the MVPs as far as acting goes in the
entire MCU there's a lot of incredible
acting against MCU I think Oscar Isaac
is definitely a highlight I think when
we get to the top ten I'm not going to
give my top 10 away but a lot of those
are highlights but this one was hard to
not put any higher out of sheer Talent
of acting it's just screen time and that
is nebula nebula is in every movie The
Scene stealer Ace
you watch end game and everyone is going
through trauma and there's something
about what Karen Gillen brings while
covered in makeup with these giant black
eyes that you just want to help so badly
she's so tortured so broken so her
hero's journey is coming from a place
like a lot of people are like six feet
under she's like 20 feet under she has
no reason to want to help anyone she has
no reason to be in any way endearing but
that fight between her and nebula in
Guardians 2 is so painful because you
feel the punish twice every blow that
lands you feel for nebula and Gamora and
I don't know how nebula manages to be so
interesting every time how much pain you
could feel for this character but she
always does the thing that's gonna make
you feel for her and she still does I
don't know I just I love nebula so much
that's another whole video nebulous
great number 33 is a character that
immediately stole my heart he has a
character from the comic books that they
literally don't even refer to as the
name because it is so outdated and
doesn't work at all
maku is not a character I ever thought
would be like that's the guy from the
comic to the screen Winston Duke makes
this character work and they have so
many details that tie into his original
name by the way is manape manape does
not work maku is a character who is
leading a rival tribe and as a rival is
never quite an antagonist you don't ever
have anything against this guy you
understand where he's coming from in the
movie Black Panther everyone's
perspective is is fair to a point even
killmonger's worldview is pretty much
just an American world view so you
really need to have lots of nuance and I
think Baku has the most nuanced
perspective outside of t'challa and
that's that's the strength of the
character is he's protecting his people
he's protecting wakanda even though he's
been ostracized out to the mountains and
then to tie in the comic elements like
you know he's eating a vegetable in the
second movie as a comedic element but
it's also like a favorite vegetable of
Apes so they make it a man ape thing
it's just it's genius when they've done
this character genius how human they've
made a supporting character and how much
you want more of him uh I'll take an
embaku movie tomorrow sign me up Winston
Duke please number 32 okay so you've got
the original Avengers right you've got
the the ogs in the first film you've got
the six they all got a tattoo together
when you're replacing any of those six
you are screwed like how are you going
to replace Captain America well you got
Sam Wilson how are you going to replace
Thor we don't even know yet how are you
gonna replace Iron Man we talked about
ironheart earlier it's not easy Hawkeye
gave a whole show six hours for Kate
Bishop who you may know we haven't
talked about yet I was like man how are
they possibly going to replace one of
the first to die Black Widow
is a very beloved character and Yelena
balova is another assassin and it's all
Florence Pew man Florence Pew is
immediately captivating I mean that's
that's the subtitles video top 75 Heroes
captivating but Jolina bolova is so much
every time she's on screen she's funny
she's terrifying you wanna hate her but
you can't she's the sister you don't
want but love it's exactly what she
needed to be and that's the only way we
can get another Black Widow in the
universe if you're gonna have another
Russian Assassin from the Red Room that
doesn't feel like a copycat I can think
of no other way and the fact that she's
had such beautiful Redemption so far the
fact that she's done so much heroic
already in her limited appearances such
a hero such a Titan love me some Elena
bilova number 30.
two number 31 maybe the person with the
least screen time in the top almost 30.
we're getting again into the I could
have moved anyone around here this one
is the she gets she gets pretty high up
because of the oh my God how did they do
this of it all Elsa Bloodstone has like
20 minutes of screen time most of which
are in black and white I'm more invested
in the future of what Elsa Bloodstone
does in the MCU then some of the
characters you met 14 years ago I don't
know how they did this but a character
that's literally a monster hunter from
the comics a very one note every 90s
let's show some boobs character that
doesn't really get a lot of stretch well
that's all she does is stretch she
doesn't have the character integrity
that you'd want a full-fledged lead to
have immediately Giver in werewolf by
night you care about her family you care
about her history you care that she was
mistreated you care about what Monster
hunting she's gonna get into you wanted
to get the Bloodstone you want her to
treat Ted with respect and she does you
care about like she her son are
incredible the physicality of Elsa
bloodstreet I loved her choreography as
well as the portrayal I don't know uh 20
minutes of screen time or so Elsa
Bloodstone is is number 31 lover coming
in at number 30 is an actress that I did
not know before the Black Panther movies
but now we'll watch anything she does
deny Guerrera is a Powerhouse I love
Okoye so much Okoye she makes so many
decisions that I should hate she sides
with killmonger she stays a loyal
Trooper she just does she's U.S agent
she just does as she's told she just
listens to the badge I'm not a fan of
that in Life or in characters and yet
Okoye is so great and so fascinating and
I get it I see where she's coming from
the dorm Elijah swear an oath and she
abides by that oath so much so that in
the second film I think the best scene
in the film is her versus Angela Bassett
in a battle of just sheer willpower and
an emotion and loss and what's honorable
is leaving the staff and leaving your
post and that's what she does because
she's honorable every decision she makes
is about honor and that's in incredible
and it's never boring and sometimes that
can be in a character akoye is such a
boss I love her a lot number 30. coming
in at number 29 is a character that made
a giant mistake which cost us half the
people in the universe but that's human
and he's half human Star-Lord I do feel
like gets a lot of oh my God why would
he do that because that's the character
you need to factor in the emotion of
humanity the human element of these
Heroes is so important and that's what
separates these characters from a lot of
other characters and that's what
separates this universe I think that a
lot of other shared universes the human
element and a lot of times you need
Star-Lord for that look at the Guardians
of the Galaxy they're all aliens very
clearly look at them star-lords are our
Island I said that earlier about Gamora
if he hadn't been so emotionally
invested in Gamora and punch Thanos it
wouldn't have felt authentic I think
that was one of the most heroic things
he did and it wasn't heroic it was human
and that's heroic being a person feeling
your emotions it's important and and I I
don't know some about that moment also
you know all the Guardians movies him
being great him being our Island him
being funny him being Charming him
saving the universe him having to dance
off for heroism but that moment that a
lot of people hate I think is really
important so it's the main thing I'm
focusing on here Star Lord's number 29
for a bevy of reasons but uh I love me
some some bold characterization through
emotion coming in at number 28 is our
new Captain America Sam Wilson as the
Falcon dude had to endure a lot of on
your left he had to be number two he had
to be a soldier he had to say yes sir
and answer to things even when he didn't
necessarily think it was right but when
he knew it was wrong he didn't blindly
do things and I think that's what makes
a hero I think that's what's really
important about the character is he has
a very important set of morals and
ethics I loved the characterization we
got with him Falcon Winter Soldier I
love getting to see his family I love
that they use Anthony Mackey's Origins
instead of the comic book Origins
because you don't have to be beholden to
the comic books I love when things work
I love when you can translate the comic
books but I think making it about
Anthony Mackey's New Orleans was much
more captivating than just following a
comic book it felt more real felt more
Earnest and the human element of Sam
Wilson is what makes him Captain America
Bucky should never have been given the
shield in the MCU it makes sense in the
comic books what they did made sense but
we saw through the course of seven
movies or whatever why it deserved to be
Sam Wilson he didn't need to be in
therapy like Bucky did he didn't have
the trauma that Bucky did or he was able
to handle the trauma better than Bucky
did he was always the right man for the
job that's not an easy role to be the
right man to take over something to be
the number two he's always been the
number two and that is not an easy role
to fill without feeling like a junior
without feeling like a lesser Anthony
Mackey did a very very great job at
becoming the man that would become
Captain America and I'm excited to see
him in those wings coming in at number
27 one of my favorite new characters in
the comic books one of my favorite young
actresses working and one of my favorite
portrayals of said character as actor
Kate Bishop is Hawkeye this this was a
show that I loved and then it just fell
apart for me in such a way that it
breaks my heart to this day I still
think it's one of the best action set
pieces in the entire MCU is that uh that
bow and arrow down the highway the the
chase sequence with the car is is
staggering but what makes Kate Bishop so
interesting is she's us in a less
specific way than Miss Marvel we have a
character in Miss Marvel that is
literally literally us right a fangirl a
Die Hard notice she's not been on the
list yet she's coming okay Bishop's the
underdog in another kind of way she's
rich but doesn't feel welcome she
doesn't have a place she belongs it's so
hard to write a rich character as an
underdog and they do it she doesn't
belong because she doesn't identify with
these people she doesn't fit into this
world and she wants to help more than
she wants to just be rich that's hard
and that's that's a hero to to sacrifice
the easy way out to do the hard thing is
a hero and hailee Steinfeld nailed that
I I was immediately so fascinated by
this take in the character because it
felt so akin to the comic but in a new
medium like I could hear the words that
were written by Matt fraction I could
hear the comic book come to life but
Haley Steinfeld was exactly it to a
level that I didn't expect to work
because I've talked about adaptation for
this translation it almost felt like a
translation but it was the perfect
adaptation love Haley Seinfeld SK Bishop
number 26 we're almost there in that top
25 is Mary Poppins y'all yandu isn't
your father but he is your daddy this is
one of the great sacrifices in modern
superhero films I love the father
betrayal and then Redemption of
star-lord's whole thing man uh the loss
of parents is a very big Marvel Trope uh
comic book Trope but it's really well
done here with yondu fatherhood isn't uh
just about blood being someone's dad is
not about just blood it's it's who
raises you who takes care of you who is
there for you as that paternal figure
and you would never have thought we'd
get from where we meet yondu in
Guardians 1 to where we end with yondu
and Guardians too ever I would never
have seen that Arc being so beautiful
and that's Michael Rooker man
self-sacrifice for your child is about
as heroic As It Gets Mary Poppins yell
number 26 Yonder coming in at number 25
is the man that brought them all
together the man who was gonna instigate
that Avengers Initiative the great Nick
Fury so Nick Fury is spy extraordinaire
but he's also a man who is always going
to do the right thing he is a man
that'll dismantle Shield he's a man that
doesn't trust anybody he trusted someone
once and it was a cat we learned later
on but he he's always the guy that's
gonna do the right thing and that's what
heroes are it's great because Samuel
Jackson is the guy that's always yelling
and you know known for his excellent use
of four letter words but there's
something inherently Charming about Nick
Fury and Samuel Jackson portrayal of
them that you trust him even though all
things say you shouldn't like he's
literally a guy carrying a gun and like
all leather like a matrix villain and
yet you're like this guy I think Nick
Fury is a fascinating take in the
character I think they elevated the 70s
Nick Fury and the Howling Commandos of
it all into a real character he feels
fleshed out got a lot of love for him
coming in at number 24 is the original
Groot remember baby Groot is a new Groot
this is OG root this is the Groot that
died in Guardians 1 and that's a huge
part of this uh we talk about heroic
sacrifices I think one of the greatest
lines in the MCU is we are group we have
a character that only can say one thing
and remember this is the only alternate
thing he ever said because every other
line from either root as so far has been
I am Groot but to this point we'd only
ever heard these amazing different
portrayals by Vin Diesel these different
deliveries these different ways of
expression through I am Groot and then
we are Groot is what the Guardians is
about they're a family they unite and
it's through the sacrifice of group
they're able to survive it's a beautiful
moment it's the definition of heroism
and it's from a giant talking tree I
I've said it so many times but I
remember when Guardians was announced it
was the first time I was worried
something a bit dignified everyone was
complaining about Age of Ultron like oh
they're using Pinocchio in the trailer I
didn't care about that it was the idea
that there was gonna be a talking
raccoon a talking tree I was like ah
this looks maybe they're selling toys I
was so wrong I didn't know James guns
work that well at this point I was a
fool this tree taught me to love again
groups number 24. number 23 is a
character that I feel like was perhaps
the most shortchanged of the entire Thor
family and that's saying something
because you know my thoughts on Jane
Foster and how much I love her I feel
like lady Sif is
so good every time she's on screen to
the point of making Thor dark World
watchable the love triangle in Thor dark
World is more interesting than a lot of
the other relationships in Marvel and
that is I think still the worst of the
Marvel films but the dynamic between
lady Sif who is the god element of Thor
and Jane Foster who is the Mortal
element of Thor being at conflict only
works because of how fascinating Jamie
Alexander is Natalie Portman's obviously
who we know he's going to end up with in
love triangles usually one character
isn't interesting The Notebook James
Marsden is so interesting but you know
it's gonna be Ryan Gosling you don't
really invest in James Marsden that man
needs a better team because he should be
a giant star James Martin's a huge star
but he should be Ryan Gosling I digress
but you know what I'm saying like when
you watch The Notebook you're not like
I'm gonna go on the James Marsden
journey I want to know everything about
Jamie Alexander's lady Sif also I would
say before Wonder Woman came out some of
the best female lead fight scenes she's
incredible on the battlefield she's the
character I wanted back most when she's
just disappeared from Thor Ragnarok it
was the character I was the most upset
with being you know shortchanged in love
and thunder and that's saying something
Jamie Alexander is so I'm gonna say it
Captivate 23. coming in at number 22 is
Don Cheadle as war machine will include
Terence Howard for the arc but is Don
Cheadle and that's actually a huge part
of this is when you take over a role
from someone else after they've been the
origin of the character after they're
introduced they literally have a line
that's next time baby like we know war
machines coming from the first Iron Man
and it's still exciting every time the
secret Invasion trailer is in part so
interesting because of the sheer depth
of knowledge of what Colonel Rhodes has
behind his eyes he knows so much more
than he lets on and it never feels
nefarious he's a hero that keeps his
cards to the chest but not in a spy way
because that's Nick Fury it's a guy that
just doesn't trust the institutions that
he was handed to and I love that
conflict the conflict of Colonel Rhodes
as a colonel dealing with the military
and being an honorable member of the
military while Tony's doing all this
reckless [ __ ] that's their whole that's
their Brotherhood and that doesn't work
if the actor and the character don't
still feel like they can stand their own
two legs we should have had an Iron Man
4 slash War Machine years ago we're
getting armor worse it's well overdue
this character can stand in his own two
legs when he's been a sidekick for so
long much like Bucky like this is a
Powerhouse character that's been like
right over here finally getting his time
in the sun I I really think he's such a
noble hero and and you know I've got my
own issues with the militarization of
choices but I think that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe could have become way
too like gung-ho recruitment video if it
wasn't for the nuanced take of Colonel
Rhodes with Don Cheadle 22. all right
number 21 this one's hard man 21 is a
character that I really like in the
comics that I like in the movies but I
do acknowledge is probably the most
different in how I think of them between
the movies and the comics in a more
negative way top three are all all
characters that I think are improvements
from the comic books this one is a
slight demerit but it's more of a
lateral move it's not it's not lesser
it's just lateral I think the Hulk has
been too teamified if you look at Ed
Norton's Hulk it's a very independent
character The Incredible Hulk was able
to be his own man I think that Mark
ruffalo's Hulk though always interesting
is only an object of the team Dynamic
and that's hard because I know Universal
has rights issues and there's problems
there with how to get that movie out and
I respect that and I'm not blaming
anyone but it always feels like Mark
Ruffalo as the Hulk is a character that
has to serve the greater MCU and that's
really ironic considering the Hulk is
the thing that destroys the MCU you know
in The Avengers The Hulk is fighting
alongside them at at the final battle
but like you know we we see him getting
you know messed up and brainwashed
delightfully and in age of all trying to
get to see the Hulk again but we don't
get to see the Hulk smash in a way that
feels authentic to the Hulk again in
like 10 years so there's just something
about the portrayal of the Hulk that I
really
that's what I'm trying to say we're at 7
8 of an arc I think when this lands and
we get like World breaker hope and we
get more of the the aggressive portrayal
of the Hulk like in the comic books it's
gonna Feel Complete so he's this High
because there's so much potential and
because I love the character and nothing
is wrong I've seen nothing wrong there's
nothing I'm saying is negative that's
why again this is really high in the
list this is almost top 20. I just feel
like it's not complete yet and I think
when it's complete it could be top like
15 maybe even top 10 depending on how
they stick that Landing but I do feel
like there's a piece of Hulk missing and
I'm excited to see that get filled the
top 20 of 75 characters this list is
long we got the only person that could
take over a very very very impossible
mantle we got a character that is a
Legacy character in the comic books but
we didn't know if that was going to land
as a Legacy character in the movies we
have a very Charming very funny very
quippy sidekick sister ensuring in the
first black panther shuri is a highlight
because she's a lot of the levity like
that movie's fun for sure but a lot of
the quips a lot of the dialogue a lot of
that like what are those uh of the movie
are shuri and that's her in the comics a
lot of the time but she's also a Regal
ass Warrior she's a badass the
characters Arc in the second movie is
kind of the great Arc of the fourth
phase of Marvel in that it is a lot of
redemption of mourning a lot of of grief
and assessing mourning and I think
Sherry does an incredible job staying on
the right side of that line you have to
waver like heroes are gonna make
mistakes and she almost does she almost
kills Neymar I think the way she comes
around and the way her connection to her
mother and the way the Queen Mother
speaks to her that that's that's her you
know good and evil right like killmonger
and Queen Mother like there's some
really beautiful elements of The Duality
of being a hero through shuri I think
she kind of embodies the whole phase
four Arc and I think shuri uh in her two
appearances that we've really gotten her
with has been a standout and sure he is
my number 20 of the heroes in the MCU
number 19 we're into the top 20. we're
doing it y'all this is a character I
mentioned before as a very very positive
thing I was talking about Kate Bishop
being a fish out of water in that she
doesn't identify fly with being rich
while Rich and she's an underdog in her
own way of feeling like a fish out of
water around that world this is a
character that is us and if she wasn't
played masterfully would have been just
ridiculed I have said before and I will
say again Community is a show written by
nerds for nerds about nerds Big Bang
Theory is a show written about nerds not
by nerds that feels like it's punching
down at nerds I I have a lot to say
about the Big Bang Theory I if you guys
want the only time I don't do negativity
you guys know me I'll do a full video on
why the Big Bang Theory hurt nerd
culture for like a decade but
this character could have been the Big
Bang Theory the MCU is what I'm saying
she could have been oh look you cute
people with your Avengers con Miss
Marvel shouldn't work this well in the
comic books Miss Marvel is an incredible
eye line into a culture that I'm not as
familiar with as most cultures and
through the Miss Marvel comic book I
learned so much about Muslim culture in
a way that is why I love comic books in
a very non-judgmental way in a just a
look how much this works for us look how
happy we are look at these things we do
in our lives in this culture all rituals
are crazy if you look at them but we we
often other cultures I love that Miss
Marvel the show leaned as heavily into
that as the comic does while also
leaning as heavily into the family
aspect I've said time and time again
Miss Marvel is the Silver age Spider-Man
of our day and I'm on vilani not only
had to be the Silver age Spider-Man of
our day but she also had to be all of us
luckily they cast someone that is
literally all of us one of the biggest
Marvel Geeks in the world just happens
to be in it now mon villani Miss Marvel
is not only a hero in the MCU she's a
hero in our world she's a delight she's
a Gateway between us and this magical
fictional world and uh everything she
does in that show is Pitch Perfect for
the character and for growing out the
world uh the New Jersey elements the
things she says to save people both
emotionally and physically the way she's
revealed to be the first mutant very
much opening up the world of like stop
judging other people Heroes don't judge
other people and she's the physical
embodiment of that and she's mom baloney
so she's great all right number 18.
talked about movie star elements a few
times in this list and some people just
have a nest some people have a movie
star quality this actor came out on
stage they announced phase four and I
was like that's a movie star I don't
know who that guy is but that is just
charm on stage as a human and that man
was simul Liu and then two years later
we got Chung Chief and I was right this
movie is one of the best origin comic
movies period and it came out in phase
four that is hard to do we are deep into
the MCU it is hard to do the origin
thing now and that's why we've kind of
skipped it a lot of the time sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't when we
skip over it this felt like it was the
MCU is already in progress and we still
got that great origin story Heroes do
what's right even if it hurts them
Heroes sacrifice this is a man literally
fighting his father this is a man going
up against everything this is an
entirely New World by the time we get to
the end of this film this is so many
great comic book archetypes used
correctly and it improves on the comic
the comic book it was written in the 70s
and it had a lot of martial arts tropes
and a lot of things that are very
simplistically toned down this added a
lot of depth and layers to it without
Shang Chi as a focal point without the
character of Shang Chi being so
interesting and so Charming again like
he's he's funny he's quippy he's
interesting he's got a lot of us in him
he's also effortlessly cool in a way
that lends itself to being a superhero
in that origin since I don't know
there's just something about Chung Chi
that is so captivating and I really
think that without simu playing him or
without the really really Pitch Perfect
writing and the way they navigated this
expanding of World it wouldn't have
worked and it's all about being a new
hero I like that the whole thing was him
getting you know his his sea legs on him
he's figuring his world out it's a great
new addition and I think she's gonna be
one of the biggest Avengers going
forward for good reason and number 17 is
Ant-Man now 17 is a tricky spot to put
this character because he's an OG
Avenger but this character is not the OG
Avenger Hank pin this is the side
Ant-Man in Scott Lang and I like that
they went this way I think Hank pen
would have been too similar to other
characters it would have been too linear
I like that they chose the guy that is
an Avenger that's an underdog and and
Scott Lang's never really an Avenger but
in this case in the MCU the guy's a
thief for good he's Aladdin effectively
he's stealing for good and I love that
take on like heroism has so many
different faces it's not cut and dry
this man will do anything for his family
he'll do anything for his daughter and I
think that's gonna come into play in
Ant-Man 3 in a big way and the heroism
of him isn't coming from a place of like
pure altruism all the time and I like
that that's so much more nuanced he's
just trying to get by he's just trying
to do the right thing he's fallen in
with an interesting crowd I don't know I
like I like that Ant-Man isn't the cut
and dry hero he could have been and I
like that they're leaning into the
Ridiculousness of Ant-Man and it's a
genius move to cast the impossibly
affable Paul Rudd everything about this
works for the Scott Lang choice and I
think that's the right choice for the
MCU especially veering from the comic
books coming in at number 16 is a man
who once was a hero and then was a
villain then he came back around through
a lot of therapy and that's important to
do Winter Soldier the white wolf Bucky
Barnes Sebastian Stan he's got many
names I love this taking the character
so much because it was one of the first
like oh my God they're adapting that
comic so quickly Ed Brubaker wrote this
winter soldier's story like a few years
before they adapted it Bucky Barnes was
like Uncle Ben he's one of the only
characters that stayed dead and I didn't
think he would work as a guy that came
back I thought one of the great
strengths of Steve Rogers was that loss
of his Robin so to speak what man did
they make that Nightwing cool when he
came back I really think they did a
great job in casting Sebastian Stan
because you trust him when you know you
shouldn't there's something about him in
Civil War where even when he's you know
doing the right thing you're like man
and that guy's a few code words away
from being a problem and there's always
that ticking Time Bomb element and
that's what keeps them interesting as a
character uh you completely know that
Bucky Barnes now wants to do the right
thing but there's this undercurrent of
what if what if what if what if what if
which is fascinating I think that's what
he's gonna play in Thunderbolts the what
if element what what's that other side
of Bucky and and you know when he's
Winter Soldier he's not on this list
this is the good Bucky Barnes that makes
this list and what makes him unique is
that anti-hero element where he's one
decision away from being like we
shouldn't have trusted him and you but
you know you want to he's so good and
he's always trying to do the right thing
he's always trying to he's with Steve to
the end of the line he's buying his
plums trying to get his brain to work
better uh he's going to therapy he's a
good guy he's a hero love me some Bucky
Barnes one of my favorite characters all
right my lucky number and I talked about
it before a character I didn't think
would work on screen and I'm so glad I
was wrong as voiced by Bradley Cooper
which still feels wrong I like I can't
even when I watch the videos of Bradley
Cooper voicing Rocket Raccoon I still
think it's a dub like someone dubbing
Bradley group it's just so good uh
Rocket Raccoon is the saddest creature
in the universe according to James Gunn
and that is going to be so heartbreaking
I think in May I think it's going to
break us in a whole new way we all love
this not raccoon we all love this man uh
this this creature this this
manifestation of all of our angst and
all of our wants like he he does so he's
Mischief incarnate man he's the Bart
Simpson of the the old school part
Simpson of the MCU he is he's always
stealing stuff and he's always like you
know he's he's selfish to a fault but
only up to a point I love the moments
where he breaks and you realize that he
cares more about family than himself but
he'll never tell you that he'll never
agree to it his conversation with Thor
in Infinity war is one of my favorite
scenes of either Thor or rocket but it's
because of our relationship with rocket
that scene Works he is the best I don't
know I love this character so much he
he's an ultimate hero because he can
leave at any point he can build
something to get you know get out of
here he could have left forever ago he
was doing it for the money we meet him
teaming up with Groot to kidnap
Star-Lord for money but he's always
wanted family and that's what makes life
worth living is that that connection and
we see that in every decision he makes
Love Rocket Raccoon number 15. all right
number 14 is another of the original og6
the only one that didn't get a movie for
a while now Blackboard didn't get movie
for a while poor these two poor
characters Hawkeye y'all Hawkeye finally
got a show and we got to see the glory
that is Jeremy renner's take on Hawkeye
I use every man a lot it is the thing I
like about heroes I like characters that
feel like you can run into them on the
street and then they'll do something
otherworldly I like extraordinary but
you need the ordinary as an option
Hawkeye is that to a t this man can do
all sorts of extraordinary things but
he's a guy shooting arrows and you know
he acknowledges that I love the
awareness of this character the scene
where he recruits or convinces Wanda to
be an Avenger is one of the great
dialogues of the MCU the scene in Age of
Ultron between Hawkeyes family and the
Avengers is my favorite scene in that
movie and one of my favorite scenes in
phase two and Age of Ultron is one of my
least favorite films in phase two it is
a is a high highlight of the humanity of
being a hero he's doing this at cost the
cost of not seeing his family the cost
of maybe never coming home to his family
he's aware that every day and he's doing
it alongside Gods who are going to be
much more likely to come home than him
that's a hero knowing your sacrifice and
still putting that vest on and shooting
your arrows at aliens that's a hero gym
Runner is the every man that needed to
play this character I think he's one of
the slept on cast decisions like when we
talk about great castings in the MCU we
don't talk about Jeremy Runners Hawkeye
enough we would not have a good Hawkeye
without this personification he can very
easily go wrong great uniting of
character and actor as well as utilizing
this character in this world in the
original Avengers if you don't have the
human element that movie does not work
nearly as well and it's it's smart
they've kept him around number 13 okay
so I feel like this character is gonna
be a lot higher on other people's lists
or a lot lower but I feel like 13 is now
where people would put this character I
really struggled with where I put this
guy because I like his movies but don't
love them I like this Trail but I love
it more than the comic books often he he
doesn't always settle well with me and
that's what's interesting but I still
have to put him high Doctor Strange
y'all Dr Strange is the master of the
Mythic arts in the comic books he has
been close to that in the movies what's
tricky has been in a Cumberbatch plays
him exquisitely but I like him better in
the team movies than his solo movies but
for the opposite reason of the Hulk with
the Hulk I feel like he's got a little
bit of of handcuffs to what storytelling
you can have because he's stuck in the
team movies whereas Doctor Strange feels
like he's emboldened when he has the
versatility of playing with a team I
hope that makes sense what I like about
him as an Avenger is his his sense of
humor and his tenacity and temerity all
work on bouncing off of others but I
don't necessarily find it as captivating
in Solo Endeavors and so that's why he's
like in this strange spot where I'm like
man I almost want him in the top 10 but
I also want to like 20. so 13 is Doctor
Strange it's more of a personal conflict
with the character than maybe anything
he's done obviously he's sacrificed so
much uh he has spent eternities battling
he's come to bargain he has lost his
love over and over again through the
Multiverse and was willing to because
that's what Heroes do he's done all the
things that make you a hero I I just
want to see him I think much like Hulk
there's just one piece missing that I'm
really excited to see get filled all
right top 12 you lovelies we are into
the top 12. let's talk about Thor Thor
has been on a walkabout from the jump
Thor's been trying to figure out who he
is what he wants where he belongs and I
love that in a heroic character I am on
record since end game of my great love
of the crosshairs of the big three The
Big Three being Captain America Iron Man
and Thor and they they position them
very clearly especially an end game as
that big three in the comics they're the
big three of The Avengers you got cap
going from a more selfless character to
making a selfish decision and Iron Man
going from a more selfish character
making a selfless decision and through
the middle is Iron Man and through the
middle is Thor figuring out who he is he
is always seeking knowledge he is always
seeking what his Destiny is he's always
losing losing family members he's losing
friends he's losing a sense of identity
like the man is lost as a character that
would make a lot of people eventual that
would make a lot of people depressed and
it does he's depressed he's vengeful
certainly but it never puts him out he's
never out of the game he's never on the
sidelines he gets back in there he will
always fight for whoever's left the
scenes I again bring up rocket and Thor
the scenes with these two outcasts that
have lost everything or talking that's
Thor man that's the tone that's the man
and uh I do consider his they're the
rockiest for me but I think that's part
of it is like this is a man always
searching I feel like the movies are
searching too but just like the
character they keep finding new ways to
make this character and he's higher than
my other missing a piece characters
because I feel like it's part of his
identity I feel like Hulk and Doctor
Strange are missing something Thor
missing something is part of what drives
him and I think it's really beautiful to
make a god
be seeking Humanity as his narrative and
I think that's what Heroes do uh so I
love me some Thor he is number 12. all
right number eleven I'm gonna call her a
hero and I'm gonna say she is a hero and
we're gonna you know acknowledge that
she's also on the villain list just like
another one of my top 10 coming up this
is a character that is both a hero and a
villain just like they are in the comic
books but when she's a hero she has no
right to be and that's what makes her
even better a hero this is Wanda
maximoff this is a miracle child who was
trapped you remembered uh trap you
remember torture uh she is is kidnapped
by Hydra we meet her in a Cell alongside
her brother being manipulated with her
powers this is a character that has gone
through the ringer and yet she still
helps people she's lost everything and
she still helps people she she had the
incident where she kidnapped an entire
town and she's so good at her core that
we still felt for we still understood
where she was coming from we still
wanted to help in some weird way we
still felt bad when she was like
apologizing I don't know there's just
something so good about Wanda and Liz
Olson brings so much Humanity to this
this Scarlet Witch of a character she's
a witch but she's seeking how to be a
good person I don't know they're magic
there's magic in this character she has
every right to be evil and that's part
of my issue with Multiverse Madness
we've talked about that a lot she has
every right to be evil and she chooses
good and she does it while fighting some
of her own instincts in some of her own
history and some of her own you know her
powers are manipulating others and she
doesn't choose to do that often she's
good she's a hero she's she's Wanda a
little wanna Maxwell number 11. all
right we're into the top 10 and this is
a Fitting Place for my second most
controversial pick maybe of this whole
list and it's another Spider-Man we had
number 50 be controversial now we're
talking number 10. Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man is my number 10 and he is now
part of the MCU thanks to Spider-Man no
way home and he is very high up because
I think he is the most accurate
representation of Spider-Man from the
comics now that's only a a part of this
four situation of my my parameters here
for what makes a hero he owns his faults
in a way that most Heroes don't he talks
about being angry and swinging and
hitting too hard and not being able to
let that go his journey is constant
reflection he's also amazing and doesn't
see it he's self-effacing he's very to a
fault uh overly humble he he kind of you
know self-flagulates like the man
doesn't realize how great he is and that
that's also heroic in its own but it's
also Spider-Man whatever the opposite of
boastful is is truly what Spider-Man is
when he's in the costume he puts on the
mask and he's boastful as a defense
mechanisms to stay calm while he's doing
crazy stuff as soon as he's Peter Parker
he's very openly no not this guy
demoralizing and I love that Andrew
Garfield is able to capture that while
being so Charming Andrew Garfield I
there was this weird thing where Andrew
Garfield was cast and people were like
he's too handsome he's not nerdy enough
you can to be nerdy and have good genes
and also like Pier Parker was never like
that weird schlubby boy like it was a
very weird thing where like handsome
doesn't equal cool and skateboarding
doesn't equal cool there was decades
where skateboarding wasn't I don't know
I have a whole problem with the The
Amazing Spider-Man uh era of of judgment
on Andrew Garfield and I think that
rubbed off into the present so when you
look at the actual Arc of the character
his journey is about getting knocked
down and getting back up Spider-Man's
very much Rocky right like you got
Spider-Man a lot of the iconic images
are Spider-Man under Amazing Spider-Man
2 33 the cover him under all that rubble
and and not stopping and pushing them
through which they used with Tom Holland
very literally but that's Spider-Man he
never he never lets it get too much
losing Gwen Stacy losing you know
Captain Stacy losing Uncle Ben losing
Aunt May losing he loses everyone but he
always knows if he can save one more
person it's always about saving one more
person I feel like Andrew Garfield is
the Spider-Man that's always wanting to
save one more person to me that comic
book version of the character there is
one Spider-Man left he's in the top 10
as well but I mean I'm a spidey guy so
the two Spiderman but I I do feel like
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man doesn't get
enough love and I do feel like he's
gotten these three amazing portrayals
and he deserves me in the top 10 because
he is that Superhero Arc to a t we see
the character grow from one to three and
we see what it means to be a hero the
moment he catches MJ and it completes
that full Arc that full Journey God hero
[ __ ] it's great coming in at number nine
is the anti-hero of the MCU the villain
of the Avengers that has become a hero
and this much like Doctor Strange is a
hard one to place because he is
certainly a hero but where do you put
Loki like at the end of the day you love
that you don't know to trust him but
through Tom hiddleston's portrayal
through the show especially you know
he's gonna do the right thing and I love
that half the time we've had him on
screen I think literally half the
appearances he's done the backstabbing
he's done the wrong thing but the latter
half he's done done the right thing like
Avengers Thor dark World bad guy end of
Dark World sacrifice comes back
duplicitous in Ragnarok at the end of
Ragnarok fully good seemingly love and
thunder not present Infinity War good
time displaced end game not present Loki
show all good it's literally like half
and half I think but you want to believe
in him to me there's something
inherently heroic in the character
they've actually reframed the character
in the comics he's no longer the god of
lies he's the god of stories now I do
believe and I'm not a mythology major I
think God of stories God of lies are are
more synonymous in the the old school
mythology again I don't know I don't
know Norse mythology as well as I know
comic books but in the comics they've
reframed him as the god of stories he's
such a good hero Tom Hiddleston portrays
him so beautifully in such a positive
way that we want to believe in him
they've Rewritten the comic books that's
a hero that's awesome that's exciting
it's retroactively changing the
character Tom hiddleston's so
captivating we want to love him so much
I don't know there's just something
inherently altruistic about even being
mischievous through the guise of Loki
number nine coming in at number eight my
favorite drunkard who finally got the
screen time to tell some of the stories
she deserved in love and thunder a
character I want to get her own movie or
own TV series a scene stealer and a half
Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie I love every
scene Valkyries in I don't love Thor
love and thunder as much as I I
initially did at first viewing I don't
love Ragnarok as much as many others
these aren't my Peak MCU films like the
Thor movies just haven't sung for me
that much but this is my number eight
pick and it's another Thor character
Valkyrie there's something about her
this is a character who lost everything
in front of her eyes she lost the love
of her life right in front of her and
they cut the scene which felt extra dark
and ironic in hindsight you're like I've
lost everything even the scene
validating my loss of everything and
they finally gave her that in love and
thunder I loved the rare screen time
where we got to talk with Valkyrie where
we got to digest what she'd been through
and how much she was still willing to do
and not only is she willing to be a hero
on the battlefield she's willing to do
the day-to-day mundane stuff and that
isn't talked about enough sometimes
being a hero is dealing with being a
mayor like she's literally running new
Asgard she's doing the day-to-day
civilian level stuff and fighting the
big fight she's a day-to-day hero and a
big hero she's a public figure of Asgard
she's doing sponsorship deals as a
goddess she's enduring all this I don't
know the the scenes where she's that
beautiful side of the van art that was
Ragnarok with her fighting those
displays that heroism being the last of
her of her people like being the last
Valkyrie I don't know there's there's
something about this character that I
really that really speaks to me and I
really want to see more of Tessa
Thompson Valkyrie is my top 10 she's my
number eight all right coming in at
number seven is Vision I actually had
Vision at one point at number three
vision is a great character to me
because not only is he worthy he wields
mjolnir deftly and easily not only is he
a character that could be one note he's
a synthazoid he is an offspring he's
he's the idea something uh but he is the
anti-ultron in a positive way that is
both literal and metaphorical right so
Ultron is uh Humanity gone awry it's
seeing the internet and seeing all the
trauma we've caused and going like nope
get rid of humanity the only way to save
the world vision is the opposite he's
the polar to that he's we always need to
believe in others we always need to have
hope even when things go horribly wrong
white vision is literally like a
physical a visual manifestation that I
love this character that you have the
opposite of Ultron and they they spin
out of Iron Man right like when you when
Iron Man and Thor have a baby it's this
this character and between the ship of
Theseus conversation and between what he
went through in one Division and his is
having to see want to go through all
that and having to suffer and still
trying to stay the The Rock he needed to
be try to stay centered try to try to be
there for her no matter what but also
trying to be a hero seeing the horrible
things she was doing there's just so
much depth in this character and Paul
Bettany brings so much heart to this
synthazoid I want a vision show very bad
there's rumors that we're getting one I
think this is one of the most
interesting like we could dissect this
character for days choices decisions
those are the same thing koi but you
know what I'm saying like what the way
he sees the world is so fascinating uh I
love me some Vision one of my favorite
heroes in the MCU and I don't feel like
he's talked about enough I don't see a
lot of lists putting Vision at number
seven but that's where I believe he
belongs Vision all right we're into my
top six and fittingly my six is one of
the OG six Avengers we got black widow
now obviously sacrifice has been
discussed quite a bit in this she dives
off that Cliffside saving so many people
countless people's Full Sacrifice very
obvious act maybe the most obvious
sacrifice her fighting Hawkeye puts
Hawkeye very high on my list but what
keeps Black Widow this high is every
movie there's so many moments where
Scarlett Johansson does little things
that make her to me so much more
interesting than sometimes she's written
in the comic books she wields sexuality
as a positive I think sex positivity is
really important and something we don't
really talk about a lot I think it's
really interesting that like it's
weaponized here but it never demeans her
I don't love the some of the story lines
they introduced with her they use that
as a way to empower not demean sometimes
sexuality in comics is demeaning
straight up but in in this Scarlett
Johansson was able to make it empowering
most the time uh not all the time I'm
not nobody's perfect like like the the
writers and directors and like there are
definitely shots and elements and
everything else but with Scarlett
Johansson brought was an empowerment
through sexuality which I think is
incredible and I also think that she's
never dumb and like I love when she
plays naive but not dumb and I love the
relationship between her and Steve like
them in the car and when her soldiers
said just left on seeing a dialogue and
her movie like what she does for all
those women the the freeing of all those
women she was the only girl in the
original Avengers and like you know
we're working towards equality we're
working towards an amount of female
Heroes that is pissing off a lot of
people because they're like oh my God
MCU she did this when it was her against
the world it was it was five white dudes
and her and I'm just I'm gonna get
plenty of crap from this I'm sure the
[ __ ] Todds and in cells and what was
that group and She-Hulk called her
already in the comments but there's
something really empowering about being
a woman just on your own in a team and
and she did that for so many movies and
then she got her own movie after she
died and it was still a dope movie I
like the black widow movie there's
something really strong about Black
Widow and it's a human around Gods much
like Hawkeye was but she's a human
around gods that has red on her Ledger
that she's public about she owns it it's
it's on the front she completely I've
done wrong let's go forward I'm gonna
deal with that that's my conscience and
there's something so heroic about that
love black widow Great Character great
portrayal all right number five this is
gonna be a little brief uh as compared
to the other top five but uh it's
because I've talked about this dude
quite a bit if you've seen my Noah home
reviews Etc Spider-Man Tom Holland
Spider-Man's my number five Tom Holland
ending his beautiful origin Arc with six
movies Tom Holland becoming Spider-Man
at the end of no way home Tom Holland
embodying with great power comes great
responsibility Tom Holland going through
the loss of everything that makes him
Spider-Man and doing it as a hero and
mourning and the shot of him in front of
Jonah and him shouldering everyone being
against him and it not making him a
villain him losing so much and it not
turning him and still being so wholesome
and true and but but going earning those
emotions Tom Holland Spider-Man has
dealt with the vulture uh that betrayal
he's dealt with so many father figures
lost right you've got the vulture as a
kind of father figure like a stepfather
figure the girl he loves or likes it's
high school so you feel like love but
going through that and those amazing
scenes uh a big brother in Jake
Gyllenhaal that that loss of trying to
find someone Tony Stark another father
figure lost than losing out May he's
lost all sense of family so he finds his
own family in Ned and MJ and then he has
to let them go he has to lose them by
choice to save everyone and it still
doesn't make them cynical it still
doesn't make him a bad for lack of a
better term he still wants to help
people and what does he do he suits up
he loses everything he loses the tech he
loses all the things that made it hard
to identify with him as the Spider-Man
the street Spider-Man and he makes a
suit after his brothers he makes a suit
that's the blend of Toby's and Andrews
which is one of the great like oh my God
the universe led to this beautiful suit
and like what are the chances that all
the legal would line up and all the
story lines would line up and all the
Multiverse of the lineup we'd get this
perfect suit that is a blend of these
things but it's because these are his
brothers now he's found his new family
he's found his brothers and he wears it
on his chest literally he wears his
family on his chest and that's
Spider-Man and there's something so
special about this character and this
take I I love him he's a hero man he's
Spider-Man number five coming in number
four and yes he is a part of the MCU now
and this might seem like cheating people
might be mad and if you you feel mad
just subtract the number from all the
rest and discount this one but I'm
putting him in here because this is a
character that is one of my favorite
Comic characters and I think he's even
better in the MCU and that is hard to do
that is Daredevil Daredevil I my god do
I love Daredevil Daredevil is a
character that is racked with guilt that
is always pushed to the Limit he uses
what other people perceive as a handicap
as a strength which is something I think
is so important like I talked about with
Athena this is a character who is
everything you want a real hero to be
like he's real he does feel Vengeance he
does want to hurt people he does go
through mistakes and and trials and
tribulations I love how it really is and
then you get the shield portrayal
Daredevil is horny in all senses of the
word pun very much intended and I love
that they're not shying away from that
it's been a very not not a lot of Bonin
in the MCU they bring in Matt Murdock
who's got his share of uh notches on the
bedpost and I just love that they they
again sex positivity is so important so
not only are we getting this incredible
character that is nuanced and hilarious
and and incredibly versatile to use as a
fighter as an intellectual as all these
things Matt Murdock and shulk is
exceptional Daredevil and She-Hulk is
exceptional and you're not shortchanging
our experience at Charlie Cox is the
character of Netflix we don't know what
they're gonna do macro we don't know
what born again is going to mean as far
as continuity and those things but right
now our experience of the character
there's no way those three seasons of
the show are not part of our minds so
I'm including it for my head Canon and
that's why some people might discount
this even if I'm only including that
Shield show he'd be in the top 20 but
I'm including that so he's number four
everything I want in Matt Murdock is on
screen everything I want in Daredevil is
on screen and arguably some of it's
better than some of the Daredevil Comics
I've read and Daredevil is one of the
best written characters ever the Bendis
run the Wade run the the current
zadarski around the Miller run he's
always exceptional and he's still
exceptional on screen Charlie Cox brings
one of the best performances period to
TV and now in She-Hulk it doesn't
alienate that performance it only
broadens it that is so hard to do to add
after three years of this dark version
to add a levity that's still feels
authentic to add so I just I love it
also even in the fighting even in the
fighting like the way the fighting
styles like he's making sure no one gets
too hurt but he's still a little bit
more brutal the way he's um you know
trying to make sure everyone's actually
in the wrong he's using his law mind
while fighting is Daredevil the man is
always on he's a hero because he's
always aware literally of everyone in
the room and he does what he has to but
he doesn't doesn't take you know
shortcuts I love what Daredevil does as
a hero and he puts people down a lot
harder than other Heroes and I think
sometimes that's what's necessary while
still being inherently good all right
number three we're into the top three
now the big three I talked about earlier
The Avengers were cap Iron Man and Thor
spoiler alert two of those three guys
are left but one of them it's such an
important character that was introduced
in another movie and that's always hard
to do to not get your own movie so when
his own movie was as exceptional and his
introduction was exceptional and every
bit of this character rang true to the
actor and the portrayal I gotta give
some love to black panther number three
is Black Panther black panthers
introduced in Civil War and he's
immediately so much we lose to Chaka
very quickly we see t'challa morning and
he doesn't kill Baron Zemo so
immediately Hiro he's immediately
fighting against all his instincts doing
all those things we we see these fights
with Winter Soldier like some some Chase
elements that chase is so slept on where
they literally fight with a motorcycle
and we see the power of Black Panther
and realize that he's always holding
back and what it means to be a hero
that's both uh you know a public figure
and a hero and a leader like this is not
only an Avenger not only King he's all
these things at once the amount of
responsibility in her shoulders and then
to look at what Chadwick Boseman had to
do while privately fighting cancer the
responsibility in his shoulders play
this character when days on set are not
short and it is not not physical it is
most the time it's a long hard day if
your body's fighting itself that is I
can't even imagine so I can't separate
what Chadwick was fighting while this
character work was so incredible then a
black man Panther you know to go even
further we we have this incredible
nuanced story of like what it means to
be good and this is a hero who listens
to his villain killmonger had some
points the end of black panther is is
t'challa being such a good leader that
he listened to killmonger and embodied a
lot of what he had to say he did open up
a lot of the technology of the world he
did start sharing he did open his doors
he didn't do it as a conqueror because
he's not a bad guy but he did it as an
ambassador he wanted the world to be
better for wakanda even at Cost
sometimes such a hero such a leader both
in the actor and the portrayal black
panther is somehow Batman and James Bond
and you know a Marvel hero and he's all
those things and number three for a
reason Black Panther's such an
incredible hero such an incredible
character such an incredible portrayal
and another one that to me uh is is
elevated from a lot of the comics
because I do feel like what we got
captured so much of the spirit in such a
quick amount of time like you can read
Decades of Black Panther and you can
also watch these movies and you feel
that Beating Heart of the character and
that's so hard to capture rest in peace
to the great Chadwick Boseman and holy
crap what a portrayal of black panther
every time you showed up on screen even
in what if
um Star-Lord as uh t'challa that's a
hero like to the the way that someone
else embodying that character and and
that versatility of character like
there's just so much in this this role
top two you lovelies number two you
gotta you know you know what's left but
which one's it gonna be which which side
am I okay so a lot of people think of me
as a Captain America type and I
definitely love Captain America and a
lot of people see that as mean it's
always funny what people see is you
versus how you see yourself my number
two I think is how people perceive me
and how I present myself maybe but I
always feel like the number one my
number two is Captain America Captain
America is such a hard character because
he's such a Boy Scout it's so easy to
get this wrong I think the reason is why
it's so hard to write Superman is why
it's so hard to write Captain America he
is so much more than the Spangles and he
is such a
fixture of Pop Culture he's literally
the flag and it's so easy to mix up
patriotism and and goodness and that's
why U.S agent's such a special character
blind patriotism is dangerous and I
think it's really interesting how they
they navigated that especially with
Winter Soldier the second movie of this
guy's series they just rip it all down
and they show like hey don't blindly
listen to others these giant government
entities are not necessarily your
friends uh institutions can harm you
blindly believing in institutions can be
very dangerous that's one of the lessons
as you get older you realize like you
can't blindly trust these things as your
kid you're like that's safe that's good
it's not and Captain America represents
that to me now because the movies I
didn't always get that from the comic
book sometimes I did certainly this is
probably the character that is most
improved from the comics to me the the
highest elevation uh because I don't
read a lot of cap Comics I do now but I
didn't he is such a pure character
without being boring or not true he's
authentic and pure and that's hard I
believe in his decisions I believe in
what Captain America stands for and I
believe in LA looking at how to take
care of your countrymen without blindly
listening to your country uh and I don't
know there's there's something like you
you follow a man like Steve Rogers you
follow a man like Chris Evans and what's
great is is you look at the ark and I
and I described it earlier I say
selfless to more selfish I think that's
important yeah I think after a time you
need to choose yourself and and you know
as we get older there's only so much
time and you know cap is is literally a
hundred right so even if you're ageless
and your body age is slower you've still
been fighting that fight even if you're
Frozen I get it there's time but he's
still been fighting a very long time so
there's something important about that
lesson of like sometimes you have to
choose yourself and I'm not saying
selfish is a bad thing I'm saying
choosing yourself he chose Bucky he got
to have his dance and he deserved it he
fought long enough he he you know he
served his tours and now he's time to
not be a soldier and I think that's
really important for him to do as a
character and I think that's why he's my
number two is it's important for the
character to have that Arc and I think
they landed it and I would love to not
see Steve Rogers come back I know a lot
of people want old man Rogers I know a
lot of people want to see some takes I
think a perfect Arc is rare it would be
a sacrifice to see him back maybe Secret
Wars as an alternate but there's still
no version of our head that's going to
see Chris Evans be like no no that's
another one bring him back his Human
Torch or not at all it's a beautiful
Perfect Dark it's a well-deserved
retirement for a perfect character and
it's a character that I think is even
better than the comics love love Captain
America number two let's do number one
there's one character left you know it's
gonna be but let's talk about it my
number one hero in the MCU is Iron Man
it's interesting this is who I identify
with when I watch these movies I totally
can see making a lot of decisions he
make I'm impulsive I I want to put a
shield around my world I love that this
is a he he's so drastic that the Ultron
thing comes from him I think making
mistakes is also part of being a hero uh
I love that he wants to put a shield
around the world in Ultron and then he
ends up putting a shield around his
world in rescue and his daughter and Tom
uh Peter Parker he literally builds a
shield around his world war machine uh
Rhodes all of his people are encased in
armor he does what he can to do his
Mission he sacrifices himself the
ultimate heroic move he gives up his
life and this is a character we started
with as a warmonger this is a man
profiting off War this is a man
profiting off missiles that sees the
harm in that that grows from that so few
people go that direction I feel like
it's so much easier to get worse as a
person than better it's hard to look up
to people that are real because they are
real they will make mistakes it's also
hard to idealize people it's it's good
to have yours it's good to look up to
people but not idealize them because
they're still people so many people that
I look up to have made horrible
decisions and I don't look up to them
anymore plenty I still do but there are
examples and I think it's really easy to
lose empathy when you get to a certain
point of wealth I think it's easy to
forget people and and that's hard uh and
Tony Stark went the other way uh the
more he grew the more he opened his
heart uh even when he didn't want to
come back for Steve Rogers you know
after he had a family in that cabin
stuff he came back he knew what was at
stake and he still came back he he lived
the dream and knew that he if he went
back in time it might sacrifice
everything but he was still willing to
save half the world the ultimate
sacrifice is willing to sacrifice your
family even beyond that he sacrificed
himself not to mention you know the root
of the MCU as Iron Man uh the first
three phases anyway Tony Stark Robert
Downey Jr is the way we got here that
first movie is still near perfect still
in my top five all these movies later
charm Charisma intelligence altruism
goodness without being boring these
things are very important in a hero to
me apparently I have something in the
boredom but I guess I do the ultimate
hero and and a comic character that was
written as a challenge Stan Lee wanted
to make an unlikable character and he
did and then Tony Stark is somehow such
an enduring figure I also think he
represents Americana almost as much as
Steve Rogers does if you look at America
it's about like this American
exceptionalism it's about shininess it's
about being all you can be and Steve's
the flag but you know the machinations
of America's Iron Man the shiny suit the
being bigger and Larger than Life Steve
goes home at the end of the night Tony
goes out to party like America goes out
in parties so I think that America is
represented in these two Heroes and I
think that they're two sides of the same
coin and I think that's why the inverse
of that Arc works the selfish to
selfless and I think America should look
at Tony Stark
I think that uh there's something really
beautiful in the Arc of that character
and I love him very much and he's who I
identify with most and he's my favorite
hero in the MCU number one is Iron Man
we did it 75 Heroes I am so tired this
is the longest I've ever filmed this is
literally a three hour shoot for one
video this is gonna do it for me please
please leave a like leave a comment I
did 75 of these uh five were the second
take I'm gonna totally own that usually
these are all one take five or a second
take I'm battling sickness not covid I
got an ear infection that spread to my
nose and throat my whole head is
infected I'm suffering but I want to
make sure I did this because I had a
really fun time building this list up so
out of sympathy for my dying uh please
be nicer in the comments than you guys
sometimes are normally 90 of people are
great but the 10 that are mad are so
angry so angry so maybe five percent of
those people just lighten up a little I
appreciate each and every one of you
even the angry ones please leave a
comment like subscribe hit that
notification Bell share this with your
friends who's your top 75 listen them or
top 20 just go go crazy do whatever you
want in the comments I want to read them
I love seeing your opinions if you
strongly disagree let me know strongly
agree let me know try to do it you know
with some kindness uh that is gonna do
it if there's anything else you guys
want to see me rank leave it in the
comments below I appreciate all y'all
and if I forgot stuff I'm so sorry one
sick too I didn't re-watch any movies
before listing 75 that's 14 years of
just me trying to remember why I love
these characters luckily I love these
characters and I love you thank you for
being here reject nation that is gonna
do it uh okay I'm gonna sleep good night
bye be well stay safe happy holidays get
some sleep okay hydrate call your mom
[Music]